uh i like throwing out a fun question to
start things off so ken i really want to
know um when was the last time you
actually had to pay for a drink in japan
i pay yeah listen if if i was i would
imagine though if you're in a bar and
someone sees you or anyone sees you in
japan they would say i would like to pay
for his drink
but let me tell you about about ken he's
so low-key you don't know it's ken
watanabe when he comes to work and puts
on his costume
he becomes the kenwa tanaba you know but
when he leaves work he puts a hat on
very regular clothes very regular car
and it's like he is just blending into
the tokyo and you would never know as
ken watson
yeah hiding
hitting
um i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of uh of shows and
movies for both of you i know there must
be so much to talk about with this one
but what do you think soon to be fans of
this series would uh be surprised to
learn about the making of it
you know just
first time to
heard about this project
from jt rogers
and then uh cops
vs gangs
it's an usual
story and they're bowling something but
good point of this young
news
young newspaper writer from united
states
to getting the under underground to meet
the cops and gangs it's really
interesting
then
one more thing is uh
1990 is a big change of a society it's
analog to digital
just not technology just feeling of
people
and the atmosphere of a society and
really chaos
then
uh jt rogers has wrote a great script
and then each character has a
little bit deep
background
uh story of life
and uh
you know just we need to show the long
long time to
show
about the story and that's not movie is
this
size is a tv show but scale is a
movie more i think
yeah i mean
you know
it was really cool because
actually when we were filming it you
know it was during covid so being
like the american fishy out of water
there
it was like probably how jake felt in
the 90s because now obviously
uh it's you know
tourism there is crazy and
uh i feel like the culture in a way has
become more and more westernized slowly
but surely but in the 90s it was a
little more just strictly japanese
but because of kovid it almost was like
you know turning back the clock because
there was almost like
i really felt like wow like i'm one of
the only guys around here who's not like
a real someone who belongs in tokyo uh
so that aspect of it almost like really
helped me more get immersed into the
character into the world
um you know help me with the language
and
all of us felt like wow this is really
special that we're here right now i love
learning about like hard scenes to film
or takes that were really rough because
of camera moves or whatever so for each
of you what was a scene or sequence in
the making of this show that really
stood out for you in terms of
challenging or was just a real pain to
do
you know he tried too hard to learning
in japanese language
i think is uh most difficult language in
the world
is learning japanese
then he tried too hard then uh he
learning uh
just not language it's just culture and
visa everything he he wanted to try
then
some sequence
he wanted to try to japanese
dialogue
and
i also organized
about the uh japanese dialogue and i
connect to the ex-cops ex
news paper writer
ex-gangs a little bit scary and then uh
you know
whole dialogue i checked the japanese
then
uh he tried to uh
sequence it in japanese
and on rehearsal
i'll listen about that it's not
good
we need to back to english and uh yeah
we had a
good relationship really honestly and
then i
i tell him and then uh
we need to back to the english and then
back and of course english and japanese
is a really usual thing it's uh
different countries people
are connecting a religion has a
relationship
and it's just real
yeah it's really enjoying
yeah i remember we did that scene
where we're sitting at the
at on your car
and
i say we gotta
that
is
right
and you that was what you said do it in
english don't do a japanese but when we
filming i kept doing it in japanese
because the scene was a scene where jake
is disobeying category
and
it kind of it created an interesting
dynamic because we did have a very
honest relationship and it was funny for
ken to say i don't know your japanese is
not too good
and then i would do it in japanese and
then eventually he went
remember and that was a really good take
this is my last thing with covet is
obviously covered the worst thing that's
ever happened to this planet it's
terrible but it has been beneficial for
productions because you allowed you had
more time to um prepare like you know to
work on scripts to prepare dialects to
to get ready for the the
the production so for both of you how
did the covet shut down because you
filmed for five six days how did that
actually help make the series better
yeah
a year delay of a half year schedule
scheduled half year and then uh
i turn off the switch
but still
getting the key
you know just but we start over shooting
is so tough and uh
three days each pcl
check
and then we
need to zoning about
you know act
wardrobe hammock and what
are direct art session or something and
uh we could not speak
some
loads uh
different zoning people
then i also
didn't meet the other people
outside of a set
just focus on the character it's just
good
yeah
yeah all the restaurants were closing at
8 p.m so you kind of had to go home
yeah no they were you they stopped
serving alcohol
and then also the shutdown was great for
me because
then i got to you know i
i wasn't i wasn't too good at japanese
at first i mean i still
you know was good enough but
it was like you know we got shut down
and then we had a whole another prep
period like two or three months again
where i started taking japanese class
for the pilot again
so that that was really helpful because
then i could prepare for the pilot and
for
next episodes um so in a way the
shutdown was actually
a blessing in disguise for just
you know michael mann was like great we
got to do a whole prep period over again
and let's you know then you can get even
better at japanese
and while i was in america i was doing
zoom sessions with
my japanese sensei yeah it paid off
thank you so much guys
yeah
thank you
thanks
you